how do you stay in flow I wrote a piece
and did a video a while ago about flow
and how important it is your business
how important is to get there and stay
there because all of your best ideas and
your best creative work is going to come
when you're in that state of flow so
when it does come you've got to stay
there you've got to push everything
aside because your best work is going to
come from that and everything else
becomes secondary I got a great question
from one of my readers I can't pronounce
the name so I'm just going to go with G
my apologies but I don't want to butcher
your name and G wrote in to say I love
being in the state of flow but I have a
hard time staying with it because I feel
like I'm pushing other people away what
do I do this is really really important
when you get into the state of flow you
have to be willing to push other things
aside because this is going to be the
one moment you have to make a lasting
significant impact with your business
and it's not even your business it could
be anything anything where you feel like
you are really in the flow you don't
want to be interrupted how I handle it
is the people people in my life they
know what I'm doing they know I'm
passionate entrepreneurship they know
that I get busy at times with certain
projects and I will have to push people
reschedule set up another time because
I'm I'll write to them and say listen I
can't meet tonight because I am I'm in
the middle of something really important
I'm excited to tell you about it I want
to share it with you because it's going
to be amazing I'm really feeling this
and I'm so sorry to cancer but I have to
push it to another time so I can finish
this off it does a couple things one
it gets them excited about what you're
doing right most people don't have any
excitement in their life so they get to
live vicariously through you they get
their excitement through you and what
you're doing there they're excited for
you I want to hear what you're what
you're up to to your position in a way
where they know that you feel bad right
I don't like pushing people canceling on
them sending back a time but it's
important if I just wrote say can't make
it tonight then they're going to get
upset so if you make it personal show
how much this means to you they'll be
supportive if they're not then they're
not your friend right if I write to
someone and say listen I really can't
meet tonight I'm really sorry I've got
this super important project I'm working
on I'm really feeling it right now and I
just have to finish it off something
amazing is going to come from it and
they say you know that's that's not cool
that's really unacceptable and they shut
you down you listen you want to be
around that person that's not your true
friend the other part of it is you can
get so much more done when you're in the
state of flow it could literally be ten
times as much work in much less time
that you can free up your time the next
day to go and meet them or the next week
or whatever it is you could spend more
time with the people you love with the
friends and family in your life because
you really capitalized on your flow and
when you're focused on your business
your time spent there isn't fiddle
around thinking what to do next putting
on some fire go in checking something on
Facebook you are working it you are in
flow you are killing it the stuff you're
creating is unbelievable and the worst
thing you can do when you're in flow is
stop it to have some arbitrary time
limit on it or to have to leave it to go
meet somebody or do something else
because you can't get back to it if
you're working on something it's so hard
almost impossible to get back to that
feeling to continue where you left off
think about it when you've been
interrupted on a project
phone call quiet conversation whatever
it is to get back to where you were even
if you weren't in flow just to get back
to where you were takes like half an
hour 40 minutes it's not worth it so you
have to really think about it and for me
I've made it a conscious decision to not
interrupt my flow and to interrupt
everything else because that all becomes
secondary once i'm working on something
that i'm in flow I passionately believe
and I need to get it done now because
this is the time to make something
magical happen and magic will happen if
you give yourself the chance to build it
and if your friends can understand that
then it's time to get new friends
believe for those are watching like the
video thumbs up below and I want to hear
you have to think please leave a comment
underneath let me know what you think
let me know how you stay in flow let me
know if it's important to you you have a
question for your business leave it
underneath I'll do a beauty response
thank you so much and I'll see you soon